a lo largo de nuestra vida
todo el mundo nos habla de valores
en la casa en la escuela en el colegio
hasta en el trabajo
siempre nos repiten para hacer una
persona de bien debes tener valores no
es cierto recuerdo en la secundaria en
el típico momento cívico
la inspectora me llamó la atención
cruelmente
debe tener valores cívicos señorita
arregles ese cabello se imaginan
que te llamen la atención y te hagan
pasar al frente como modelo de mal
ejemplo por un peinado pero si eran los
para esta inspectora con ínfulas de
sargento
llevar el cabello a la moda equivale a
no tener valores cívicos que mal
en todo caso a mí tanta ceremonia tantos
discursos lo único que me provocaba era
rebeldía y llevarles la contraria
pero bueno siempre me pregunte por qué
algo tan importante como los valores no
suenan tan aburridos porque siendo tan
relevantes nos entran por aquí y nos
salen por acá
porque siempre nos hartan con el cansado
discurso debe tener valor es como si
aprender valores tuviera que ser a la
fuerza
claro cuando nos imponen algo real
vamos y nos ponemos a la defensiva
pobres valores siendo tan relevantes
quedan olvidados en un rincón
hasta que por algún evento especial nos
volvimos a traer los estrenamos como si
nos pusieran de moda
cuando cuando buscamos empleo en la
entrevista de trabajo ajá ay sí pues
decimos que somos colaboradores
somos organizados somos multifacéticos
cumplimos a cabalidad trabajamos bajo
presión tanto que resultaría imposible
que no nos contrate
del dicho al hecho
mucho trecho
en fin
fui poco a poco dejando esta rebeldía y
me adapte a lo establecido estudie me
inserte en el mundo laboral y crecí
llegué a un puesto gerencial el sueño de
todo profesional buen sueldo viajes
estatus en fin personifica el valor de
la responsabilidad laboral
en la cima de mi carrera
negociaba con trabajadores en huelga
generaba políticas de recursos humanos
realizaba arbitrajes tenía éxito
profesional pero saben
algo no encajaba y empecé a sentir culpa
y culpa porque me pasaba demasiado
tiempo lejos de mi familia y me perdía
sus momentos importantes
claro por las demandantes jornadas
laborales
decidí renunciar
sabiendo que perdía beneficios
económicos y profesionales pero se me
ocurrió la brillante idea de aplicar el
desarrollo organizacional y el liderazgo
en mi casa así que me autodenomine
gerente multitarea familiar
empecé a administrar recursos domésticos
ejercer la jefatura de transporte y
logística innovación con la cocina
liderazgo en la tabla de planchar
charlas de organización
pero lo mejor fue compartir tiempo en
familia
en esta nueva faceta estaba realmente
muy tranquila y feliz
pero esa felicidad
se cortó de golpe
con la pérdida repentina de mi hermana
fue algo devastador me sumió en una
tristeza profunda
todo quedó estancado
lo único que me rescató fue iniciar un
proceso guiado acerca de una nueva
perspectiva de lo que significan los
valores claro en ese momento de mi vida
mis valores estaban empolvados así que
no lo dude y me metí de lleno al proceso
aprendí a jugar con un set de cartas con
valores barajar colores con un eje
triaxial
algo muy profundo como si fuera una
auditoría de valores para saber cuáles
sirven y cuáles no
muy divertido
aprendí además que a más de nuestros
valores fundamentales que nos definen
existen valores funcionales esos que nos
ayudan a cumplir nuestras metas por
ejemplo si deseamos iniciar una dieta o
queremos iniciar un entrenamiento físico
no incorporar valores como la
determinación y la perseverancia
seguramente harán que fracasemos
imaginemos por ejemplo que los valores
están servidos como en un buffet cuando
vamos a la mesa de bocadillos aunque
queramos no podemos comerlos todos
podemos optar un máximo por 5 pasa lo
mismo cuando identificamos nuestros
valores aunque queramos no podemos
desarrollarlos todos querer hacerlo
puede resultar
un fracaso
ok había encontrado la brújula que me
iba a ayudar en lo que pronto tendría
que enfrentar
la dolorosa partida de mi madre víctima
de cáncer
para empeorar
en los resultados de mis exámenes
médicos de rutina
el diagnóstico
qué hacer qué podía hacer
volvía a barajar mi juego de valores mis
cartas mis colores
y encontré todo un abanico de valores
gratitud fe optimismo me dieron un nuevo
enfoque y pude con disciplina coordinar
todo el tratamiento con valentía para
recibir quimioterapias y sin fallar
asistir a las sesiones médicas
junto con mi médico
organizamos las fechas para que yo pueda
viajar asistí a un congreso
internacional conocí al creador del
juego de valores que pleno y aunque
había perdido peso y todo mi cabello
la vanidad
la moda los deje atrás el miedo la
inseguridad al [ __ ] abrace un nuevo
valor el valor de la integridad
qué hubiera pasado si no aplicaba en mí
aquel concepto de valores pensaría que
son rígidos que son impersonales que son
lejanos
el mundo sigue la vida no se detiene yo
no podía darme el lujo de quedarme
estancada otra vez como podía por
ejemplo dejar de asistir a un concierto
de rock clásico
a medianoche en el cráter de un volcán
calva ahora es un sitio turístico toco
convencer a los noveleros de mi casa
ellos son mis hijos y armamos la carpa
las mochilas del grupo y nos metimos de
lleno mientras los responsables me
decían
en tu condición está segura que
irresponsabilidad
para mí no significaba ser irresponsable
sino ser leal conmigo y en cierta forma
volver a vivir aquella rebeldía
de mi juventud
conforme el tiempo sigue pasando me voy
a dando cuenta que en cada situación de
mi vida están presentes estos nuevos
conceptos de valores saber barajar los
debe ser algo personal los valores no
son rígidos los valores sirven para que
cada uno encuentre esa brújula haber
conectado con mis valores me ayudó a
equilibrar
mi ser mi trabajo mi familia y hasta mi
enfermedad
ahora sé que en cualquier momento de
nuestra vida están presentes
por ejemplo
si nos preguntamos cuáles son estos
cinco valores que hoy hablan por
nosotros la respuesta es simple basta
ver qué resultados estamos obteniendo
así que cuando cada uno necesite de
alguna situación ahí están sus valores
mis valores hoy no son los mismos que en
mi adolescencia
son diferentes y serán diferentes de
aquí a 10 o 20 años y de la misma manera
que yo tuve que barajar mis valores en
todas las situaciones a lo largo de mi
vida seguramente todos en determinado
momento tendremos que volver a hacerlo
[Aplausos]